wir sind auf einem immer noch
besorgniserregend hohen niveau dass die
aussicht eröffnet die schlechte aussicht
eröffnet dass man das anfang dezember
nicht unbedingt so abstellen kann wie
man sich das gewünscht hatten wir werden
wohl in richtung müssen dass ein
haushalt einen anderen treffen kann wenn
er mit nicht mehr als zwei personen an
rückt also dass wir nicht zehn personen
zusammen haben oder sogar je nach
incidents zahl größe auf 25 oder mehr
kommen weil es ist klar die verbreitung
ist immer ausgegangen vom
zusammentreffen einer größeren gruppe
und noch mal wir sind im moment bei 10
das heißt wir würden weiter runter gehen
wenn wir jetzt eine fünfköpfige familie
haben die darf sie dann maximal noch mit
zwei anderen treffen beispiel wer wäre
eine möglichkeit mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren